ايليا سابا وبيكا طلاب جامعيون من اوائل
من انضم الى الاحتجاجات الاخيره في تبليسي
يقولون انهم يدافعون عن الديمقراطيه في
بلادهم ويعتبرون قانون تصنيف العملاء
الاجانب تهديدا لها
سنكافح ضد هذا القانون وكل قوانين الحزب
الحاكمي الموالي لروسيا
نريد الانضمام الى اوروبا فهي هويتنا
وخيارنا ويجب ان نحارب من اجل ذلك
سحب البرلمان قانون العملاء الاجانب لكن
التازم السياسيه لم ينتهي
فاحزاب المعارضه والمحتجون يرون في اداء
الحزب الحاكم مسانده لروسيا وتلكوا في
اتخاذ موقفا واضح من الحرب في اوكرانيا
واعاقه لمسار الانضمام الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي
ان اوروبا والولايات المتحده ولدان في حرب
اوكرانيا وهذا هو تماما موقف بوتين
بالنسبه اليهم حلفاؤناهم اعدائهم الاتجاه
الذي ياخذوننا اليه يعيدنا الى التسعينيات
عندما كنا معزولين عن الغرب وتركنا وحدنا
في مواجهه روسيا
غير ان حزب الحلم الجورجي الحاكم ينفي اي
تعاطف مع روسيا ويشير الى ان تدخلات
خارجيه اججه الاحتجاجات لاقحام جورجيا في
الصراعي باوكرانيا
بحجه ان حزبنا موار لروسيا غير ناجحه وهي
مستمره منذ عقد تقريبا ولا شك في ان
المعارضه وبعض الاحزاب تقوم بذلك لكن
الشعب يعرف موقفنا جيدا وافعلنا تظهر
حتميه موقفنا بالانضمام الى الاتحاد
ويترقب لجورجي يونا بقلق ما ستؤول اليه
الامور في ظل تصاعد الاتهامات للحزب
الحاكم ومطالبه احزاب المعارضه والمحتجين
باصلاحات مختلفه ليست هذه المره الاولى
التي تعيش فيها جورجيا ازمه سياسيه جوهرها
بين الغرب وروسيا لكن هذه المره تبدو
الامور اكثر تعقيدا في ظل حرب اوكرانيا
والمواقف الروسيه والامريكيه والدوليه من
المظاهرات الاخيره هنا جونيوس الجزيره